c'était leur premier rendez-vous de la
saison et les gymnastes du club de
morpail encour n'ont pas manqué leur
championnat départementaux après avoir
arrêté la compétition pendant 2 ans
Manon marin s'impose dans le critérium
senior et lucn prend la 3è place du
concours fédéral de cersceo chez les
cadettes c'est un petit avantgoût de de
ce qui nous attend
c'est un entraînement moi j'ai j'ai
arrêté les compétitions depuis 3 ans et
c'est cette année que je reprend donc
c'est c'est la reprise quoi comme dit
c'est que le début après va essayer
d'aller jusqu'au championnat de France
c'est pas gagn mais on va on va y
arriver lors de cette première épreuve
officielle c'est l'occasion pour Elena
novokchenova de tenter de nouveaux
programmes devant les juris une
nouveauté qui peut permettre de voir les
championnats nationaux cette compétition
là depportemental c'est c'est chaque
année un peu un peu essayer nouvel
programme on regarde est-ce que est-ce
que c'est marche se lcer là est-ce que
se difficulté donc déjà ces trois filles
qui passé j'ai déjà vu que j'ai changé
plein de choses pour
region le parcours du combattant est
encore loin d'être terminé les gymnastes
cinquantinoises devront passer avec
succès les championnats régionaux
mi-novembre avant de se qualifier aux
épreuves de zone pour enfin espérer
participer au championnat de France en
janvier
2013 avec 25